good morning everyone
welcome to St Helens the presentation
today is experimentation of the gold
experimentation and the gold standard of
data Champions are presenter today is
Tim Chan he's the lead data scientist at
statsig and let's give him a warm
welcome
[Applause]
thank you everyone for coming to my talk
I just wanted to give a thanks to the
organizers uh Pi data and all the
volunteers this is a wonderful event and
I hope you folks get something out of
this
my name is Tim I'm I lead data science
at statsig prior to statzig I like many
folks who are data scientists did not
start out as data scientists I'm a PhD
in chemistry I worked in the Biotech
Industry for many years was sort of
familiar with like how that sort of feel
that does experimentation but for the
longest time I wanted to merge science
and business and the way what I really
wanted to do was use scientific
principles use data and the scientific
method to make sound business decisions
because I felt like that was I saw too
many times like in business conference
rooms like people getting up there
putting on shiny presentations coming up
with like great stories and that's how
decisions were made whoever had the most
compelling argument
and there wasn't a lot of facts behind
it and so that's sort of what led me on
my data science journey I spent five
years at meta back then it was known as
Facebook where I did a lot of
experimentation and then I joined a
company called statsig when it started
two years ago and you'll learn that we
are very much focused on experimentation
and helping our customers make proper
business decisions
what I'll share about though is not a
sales pitch it's really what we have
learned from leading tech companies on
how they approach and build
experimentation platforms how they're
able to run 10 000 experiments
simultaneously and how they become like
data-driven organizations I'll share a
lot of their best practices these are
applicable for your companies whether
large or small
and you're going to see how this really
democratizes data which is something
which I hope everyone in this room
really hopes and wants to drive towards
and what I've seen experimentation do a
good program is it really can accelerate
the pace of innovation at your company
so and lastly I'm going to share some a
little bit about personal advice for
being the data champion
as well
but first I'll just take one slide to
give like a brief introduction about
statsig and who we are we provide uh
we've put on the slide here where Modern
Product observability Company that's a
mouthful you can think about it as we
provide analytically aware engineering
tools so basically smart engineering
tools and these are based we're not
inventing the wheel here these are based
very much on the same tools that power
product teams at leading large tech
companies many of which you will know of
such as Facebook Google Microsoft Airbnb
Netflix the core of this really is
feature flagging and experimentation
feature flagging is how you release
features to users experimentation is how
you watch what happens when those users
get those features
um just some quick facts we're just two
years old we're founded in 2021 by a
team of ex-facebook product builders
that believe very much in data-driven
product development
we're based right here in Bellevue so
we're local and we've grown rapidly
we're already actively being used by
many fast-growing startups such as
notion ancestry figma headspace and
we're currently serving insights for
across hundreds of products
uh thousands of experiments and then if
you add up all of those users in those
experiments it adds up to more than a
billion
I will start from the product analytics
hierarchy of needs
um just a sort of like framework
experimentation fits here user analytics
is the foundation of all product
analytics it's really just about
understanding your users if you're
starting from Ground Zero you it
requires defining your kpis and starting
to measure them but it can go way deeper
than that and get into understanding
funnels uh understanding user Journeys
drivers of retention building LTV models
etc etc this is a big field and while
most of these are all great methods and
I love them all to me my favorite and
the one that is the most powerful is
experimentation
um it is the most important tool in the
product analytics toolbox
because it is the gold standard for
causality really understanding what
changes cause which effect not just
correlation
it is most popular in the field of
website optimization which has largely
been the domain of marketing teams and
they the focus there is on understanding
and optimizing tactical metrics things
like click-through rates I want to make
this button be a little bit more
prominent to when users see it I want
them to click through things like I have
a sign up form that has seven steps how
did I get them to complete it
um that is what website optimization is
but now there's a field that's emerging
of product experimentation that's
starting to become pretty popular and
this is where we're doing
experimentation on things that are a
little bit more complicated than just
click-through rates because products are
complicated things like the Facebook app
are complicated things like Amazon are
complicated you want to in order to do
experimentation here you want to
understand the big picture you may be
responsible for just the conversion of
users adding items to a cart but what
does that have for Downstream teams what
does that have for other teams that are
adjacent this involves understanding
more metrics e-par metrics business
metrics ideally and also longer term
outlooks like you want to do more than
just a session you want to know is that
user are they retained for the next
month two months maybe a year
um and then even within this field of
experimentation big Tech is once again
leading the charge and they're doing
this far differently than everyone else
they're doing what I would call
ubiquitous experimentation
this is like 10 000 experiments
simultaneously being run across many
many different teams the focus here is
on driving velocity on the number of
experiments you run because experiments
are how you invent things it's how you
test ideas
it is your pace of innovation at least
that's what these companies firmly
believe
but I'll Zoom back a little bit out and
just focus like what is an A B test and
why would we even do it
um a b testing as I mentioned is like
scientific gold standard for
understanding and measuring causality uh
you essentially have two groups of users
an A and A B or a test and a control
that are fairly equivalent usually you
identify these two buckets of users
assign them by randomization you keep
all things equal on their user
experience and you make just one single
change a treatment so to speak and then
by measuring those users and comparing
them the test to the control group after
the experiment you can ident any
differences you can then assign to like
that's what happened because of your
treatment it's best known in clinical
trials and so you might imagine like I
want to cure this disease or address the
symptoms you can actually tell that but
not only that you can also measure the
safety of the drug that anything else
happen that was unexpected in prod this
is very much aligned with how product
testing approaches things we can
validate whether these improvements
we're making to our product are actually
causing the desired effect on our users
and also can identify the side effects
what might have happened that we didn't
anticipate
um
but the
the meat of this really is that in
product experimentation we can actually
just measure and validate ideas
it's actually easier to test ID and
iterate on ideas rather than design them
perfectly inside a conference room
because we're building these products
and we're evaluating these ideas using
real data from real users
product development now becomes a
scientific and evidence-driven process
and the funny thing is once these teams
product teams start adopting
experimentation there's actually a
cultural transformation that happens uh
here decisions
stopped becoming about opinions and
stopped becoming about convincing people
with a compelling argument
data wins arguments here and so I think
you'll notice that we we have a booth
outside where we're giving out hippo
candies hippos is a short for as an
acronym short for highest paid person's
opinion and that's how business
decisions used to be made
and we're advocating for you can eat the
hippo now and win with data uh teams
become hypothesis driven and it's
amazing how like scientific principles
start to come into play when you start
adopting experimentation practices and
it's an experimentation my favorite part
is exceptionally humbling there's many
times you will firmly believe that this
idea is going to work and seeing the
actual experimental results other than
either that it didn't work or that the
effect was Far smaller actually helps
hone your product intuition
um in the world of experimentation
there's a lot of ideas out there
actually just in the world of product
development there's a lot of ideas out
there and unless you're Steve Jobs
people do not have a great batting
average when it comes to designing
products or coming up with ideas in fact
the majority of features we build
actually fail when you test them and
measure them
Google and Bing state that only about 10
to 20 percent of their experiments work
and Microsoft as a whole published this
analysis that said that about one-third
of their ideas had the desired impact
one-third of them did not but like they
could still iterate and fix it to make
them good and then one third of them are
actually negative like these are
features we shouldn't even we should
just cancel and turn off and get rid of
um you can think of this as like once
you're actually able to measure these
ideas you're now able to stop the
features that are red you're able to
improve the ones that are gray and you
ship the blues and you book those wins
um now for your company you may not be a
Microsoft or Google
um the batting average will vary
depending on your size and maturity of
your product and we have found that with
our customers that actually early stage
companies have a huge advantage in the
realm of experimentation they have
actually higher success rates there's
more low-hanging fruit these are usually
under optimized products that aren't
following best practices and sometimes
in a rush to get an MVP out the door it
was just important to build something
and now you can go back and actually
test what happens if we start making
improvements so they'll usually have
more Blues
um and less Reds but still just blocking
those Reds is usually a big win for your
company already in terms of like its
progress to making a good product
and another secondary effect here is
like once you're actually able to
measure the impact of the features this
pie actually grows because now you can
act because you can tell which features
are good and which ones are bad you
don't have to be careful about building
features anymore you can actually test
even more ideas with the confidence to
know that you'll be able to identify
those winners
now what if we say we're data driven but
we don't experiment and the traditional
way is you say like listen we have
metrics and we follow them on dashboards
and we want to know what happens and I
for everyone who's been a product data
scientist you've come into work and
you've seen a metric on your dashboard
suddenly go up or suddenly go down and
you have Executives that come up to you
and ask you what happened
and you play this game of like okay what
did we do what did we change what might
be going on in global events you ask
teams around you what else did what did
they know and you start putting together
a really good story
um and this is a chart the S P 500 it
has lots of ups and downs but this is
this could be a chart for any company
for example if this was revenue for
Amazon this could this could be it
um and my favorite thing is like like
the S P 500 if you were to tune into
like business news at the end of the day
um the folks on TV or the folks on those
journalists have perfect explanations
for what happened today
um they're great at explaining with high
accuracy but they can't predict anything
that's going to happen tomorrow
and so same thing happens when you're
looking at your own company's dashboards
and I call this reading the tea leaves
because sometimes you see what you want
to see
um
and you actually have a lot of trouble
actually understanding what's actually
going on for real
um
there's a lot of noise some of this is
internally because your products are
always changing your users are always
changing some of this externally your
competitors could be up to things
um but with experimentation the key here
is that test versus comparing your test
group versus control group controls for
a lot of those factors those
externalities which is why we're able to
get high precision and so pretend this
is your Revenue chart
um which is the S P 500 I have injected
in here a 10 lift to revenue that's over
10 days 10 is a really big deal uh for
for any company and you would hope that
you'd be able to see it in this
dashboard right
um you know where is it is it is it at
that Peak is it at the is it happen
right at the bottom when it starts to
recover
I picked a random day
um and that is actually today but but
exactly one year ago and you can see
here that
you that would not have been one of the
ideas you would not have known that 10
Improvement came in right on at the end
of April because you can't see it
because day-to-day variability is high
week to week month to month uh and all
Top Line business metrics tend to look
like this and 10 is like a pretty
material difference the fact that you
couldn't even pick that up in a
dashboard means that like this is not
the way uh to understand the impact of
your features
now with all that I've shared about
experimentation
we still find that even companies that
are adopting this aren't really doing it
fully at scale there's still a lot of
problems and experiments and in most
companies
a b testing is really only done on a
very limited set of features really only
the tip of the iceberg
and why because experiments that these
companies require a lot of heavy lifting
requires a lot of effort for engineers
to set up the experiment to assign the
users you need to make sure that the
experiment is working are your groups
properly balanced are you logging
exposures you're logging metrics
correctly and then when you do the
analysis which I think folks in this
room can relate to this is exceptionally
tedious and time consuming actually to
be able to compute experimental lifts
for test and control across possibly
dozens of metrics
um what this ends up being is this
process becomes highly error prone often
done ad hoc every single time a new
experiment comes through a new process
is invented
people don't trust the results for that
reason
um and very few things actually end up
getting tested uh which is sort of sad
but when you go when you look at the
companies that are doing it correctly
they're actually doing something called
Product observability they are measuring
and testing every single change that
goes out to users and I saw this very
much at Facebook as well experimentation
actually hasn't become as no longer the
domain of just data science teams it
becomes standard engineering best
practice it's an engineering tool and
just like unit testing your code adding
QA adding monitoring and tracking error
rates experimentation is just another
step in knowing that your code Works
um and I'll share an anecdote when I was
a data scientist at Facebook and
Engineers show me like he did a one-line
code fix very obvious typo in the line
of code and he's like I'm just going to
fix this typo it's like do I really need
to put this behind an experiment
and I thought about I was like well this
obviously works
um because there was a typo before and
you fix the typo but I thought about it
and I said well what's the harm in doing
a two-day test I was like there's no
cost in setting up an experiment at
Facebook because the infrastructure was
there and it's trivial he just had to go
and turn on the tooling and so he did
that
and he found out we were able to see
very clearly after two days that uh that
he fixed the bug he was intending to fix
we also found out that Downstream
another bug was introduced so and
everyone knows who does coding is like
sometimes you fix something here you
have a problem down here that was what
was happening
um to Facebook's users and we would have
only been able to pick that up through a
b testing and being able to a B test
even trivial changes that is really the
power of what happens when you start to
test every single change and when
experimentation becomes an engineering
tool
this brings us to something which I
would call Modern experimentation
culture and so experimentation at this
pace and scale actually changes a
company's culture they become more data
driven there are parts of this I've
explained experimentation I'll explain
the modern part and the culture part
it's modern because in today's world
products are complicated and especially
in the level that we understand how
users engage with them
experimentation is more than
understanding a single metric it's
understanding the full ecosystem impact
of your changes I'll give an example if
you're YouTube and you want to change
how ads work
you understand that you will possibly
drive up Revenue but it may come at the
cost of user engagement
is that important for you to understand
you bet it is because of that engagement
is not favorable it's not great for your
product
so there are often trade-offs synergies
that happen another example is like if
your Facebook videos and you want to
make want to get more video content on
the platform is that going to affect how
you interact with your friends and
family and is that what your Facebook
should be doing
you'll want to understand longitudinal
effects are these effects and changes
you're seeing just novelty effects or
are they actually durable will they last
the month will they last to the next
year
in general you want to understand deeper
and more meaningful metrics
um culture culture is all about exp
these companies is all about velocity
it's all about your pace of innovation
it's where data is democratized it's
accessible to PMs and Engineers not just
data scientists it becomes pragmatic
it's not about the complex stats it's
about making it interpretable
understandable and actionable when you
see results
these teams that do experiments start to
become metrics obsessed they start to
share information between them data
becomes king and opinions actually don't
matter as much anymore
now I you think you're thinking that
these companies on the right the
spotifys the Facebooks uh of the world
like what they're doing is not
applicable for me and that's actually
not true there's many steps on on making
your company better and more data Savvy
and more experimentation friendly and we
call this the walk jog Run Fly framework
and no matter where you are on this
there's benefits to like tackling your
current challenges and trying to up
level your organizations to the next
level and I just want to sort of
acknowledge that like this is a cultural
change cultural changes that companies
are hard to do but experimentation is an
exceptionally powerful lever to get
folks to start really understanding the
power of data and how to make decisions
and now I'll talk about my favorite
slide which is that stats engines don't
build culture we have a lot of customers
that come looking to replace their
statistics engine looking for an
experimentation tool and if it's a data
science customer the focus is usually on
the left they're focusing on the stats
engine they're asking questions like are
you Bayesian or frequent tests do you
support the man Whitney U test what
about multiple comparisons what level do
you winsorize how do you know that's
good these are actually all important
questions I won't deny but it actually
misses where we see experimentation
programs fail
experimentations fail when you're not
able to drive proper experimentation
culture when you don't even have metrics
being plumbed in correctly when you are
having a hard time setting up
experiments where setting up the an
experiment is your bottleneck it's the
hardest thing to do and it's not coming
up with the ideas
and you are not testing every single
change that is the harder part
and so that's why I'll share so the
experimentation best practices there's
many books and blogs out there that do a
really good job and I can recommend them
if you want to come talk to me
um but one thing that we have done as a
data science team at statsig is we spend
a lot of time speaking with experts uh
in the field these are Folks at top
companies such as Netflix Spotify eBay
they're doing a lot of experimentation
and what we found was a lot of the
Practical aspects of experimentation are
actually locked up and not published and
there are a few common themes which I'll
share here it's like number one I've
said we need to make experimentation
really accessible experimentation should
be a team sport it should be
standardized and not gatekeepered by the
data science teams
um it's you should have standardized
methodologies uh in place uh it's really
important to have really good defaults
that apply across your company's set of
experiments but the reason why you
should standardize and not customize it
for the task at hand is that it makes
the results comparable across your org
if team a claims they lifted Revenue two
percent and Team B cleanser lift the
revenue three percent you know we're
actually comparing Apples to Apples
they're using the same definition of
Revenue calculated the same way
um these results now become trusted once
that you're not when you're not
customizing it which removes an
important source of bias they're all
using the same metric Source things are
consistent reproducible and reliable
um holdouts holdouts are super important
to just understand
um what is happening you have usually
have a set of users that are not
receiving all the changes your company
is doing you can start understanding
like are we actually making good
decisions if everyone is calling
everything a win does it do we actually
see that in the long term
um
I'll dive into a few of these things are
my favorite this is a picture of the
static console but it's more just a
highlight and illustrate what I would
call the progressive disclosure of
complexity I will acknowledge that
statistics is complicated and in order
to make it approachable intuitive you
have to make it look like a dashboard
um and and make things easily understand
but yet you still want to make sure that
all the complexity and Nuance of
Statistics is still there somewhere and
so this is what we show we show usually
test versus control so these are these
are lift and when something is
statistically significant we color that
lift with confidence intervals in green
when something is negative and
significant we color in red and when
it's ambiguous I.E the null hypothesis
is not refuted we put it in Gray
um this is really easy to understand
it's really accessible but data
scientists will definitely want to dive
in into the details really understand
the assumptions in here understand the
nuances of data Maybe understand a
little bit more what goes into those
numbers and calculations so we do
something called the progressive
disclosure complexity if you hover over
any of these we show you a scorecard IT
services a few more metrics such as if
this is a sum of total purchase dollars
we'll actually show you what actually
dollars were triggered by the test group
what dollars are contributed by the
control group
if you wanted to go into further we
actually provide a whole bunch array of
different metrics in that view details
card for example this one's my favorite
chart it's a day since first exposure
you can actually understand that
sometimes when a user sees an experience
on day Zero they will have a certain
reaction to it sometimes it's favorable
for example brand new shiny pink button
that has unicorns on it great I want to
play with this for a little bit but then
maybe after a week it gets boring and
then that effect starts to wane or is it
possible that the new feature you've
shipped actually drives engagement long
term you can actually sort of see that
as it sorts of lifts over time this
gives you a little bit more Nuance on
what's going on
um this is probably my most
controversial take is that people think
experimentation is only in the world of
large companies you need millions of
users from the experience and I'll um
for example Bing has shared a long time
ago a 50 shades of blue experiment where
they were trying to tune the color of
blue uh on their search engine this is
something which you absolutely need
Millions if not hundreds of millions of
users for but the secret of big Tech is
that they use the same tooling they do
for these experiments with millions of
users that they would for their early
stage products
um exactly the same thing and because
it's because startups have one huge
Advantage is that they have potential
they have upside
um
and and they shouldn't be looking for
those point one percent wins if you are
a startup and you're trying to find 0.1
wins you are not going to succeed in the
long term you need to be looking for big
opportunities 20 wins 50 wins these are
low with the hanging fruits these are
big changes you're doing to your product
um you're not fine-tuning colors and
while big effects are
are very unpredictable in terms of
directional magnitude so experimentation
can help in there even the ones that are
obvious is still important is still
important to quantify it it's still
important to know is it a how big of a
win is this what are the side effects
that are happening and it's because
ecosystem effects are often complicated
uh I have the um the formula in the
upper right is actually the sample size
power what would you do before an
experiment if you wanted to determine
how many users you have in an experiment
you need to get to make sure it's well
powered
um and the N is the number of users
Sigma is the variance of your metric
Sigma squared is the variance of your
metric and that Delta squared is the
effect size you expect to see and if
you're doing a bing 50 shades of blue
experiment that effect size is going to
be 0.1 percent somewhere in that realm
but if you're a small company that
affects size is going to be like 10 20
30 you'll notice that there's a squared
term on that that is why this is
actually far more important than a
number of users
there was another paper published uh by
some folks that actually analyzed uh
what happens if we look at startups who
are running experiments or do we
actually see that they have meaningful
performance so this this paper did a
analysis of 35 000 startups over four
years and they did a
um they they basically did an analysis
where they controlled for all sorts of
factors that would affect the startup
success and even after
um correction they were able to find
that the ones that adopted a b testing
on their website
um had increased performance as well
plus 30 to 100 after one year of
adopting it
um
and
this is a really good paper see we can
from our customers we can sort of see
that like we are seeing that they're
able to for example just stopping the
bad changes is already a huge win for
your your companies
um
there are several other things that this
paper had sort of cited that those
companies are actually able to build and
iterate products a lot faster about 10
to 20 faster and they firmly believe
that this is from because of a culture
that starts to get introduced of idea
generation and this effect actually
compounds over time the companies start
becoming better
over time
another thing that we cut that we find
that our customers often ask about is
like listen I'm a data scientist I want
to control for every single Factor but
now my team wants to run more than one
experiment we want to run two
experiments how do I handle this and the
gut instinct for most scientists is
let's keep those experiments apart the
users in experiment a should not be the
use of an experiment B we say this is
not you don't overlap the experiments
but it's important to keep in mind that
an app like the Facebook app has 10 000
experiments running at all on any given
time users are assigned to all 10 000
experiments and have the potential to
interact and the reason why that they've
decided to do this is that if you carved
up your user base 10 000 times your
sample size starts to become really
small you have your experiments now take
much longer to run you have hurt your
experimental velocity and your pace of
innovation
and in this game of experimentation and
Innovation velocity is really important
so my recommendation to most folks is
overlap your experiments you it
maximizes your experimental power it can
introduce noise but I but
um controlling for this sort of noise is
I I think is
uh
it's not an effective use of your time
um and I'll show you because in our my
experience interaction effects when one
experiment actually affects the results
of another are very rare it's highly
overrated strong interaction effects are
exceedingly rare and most times effects
are additive and directionally accurate
so it will lead to the same product
decision in the end
and the best way to really to quantify
interaction effects is to do a long-term
holdout
um
so I firmly believe that controlling all
these effects is an illusion and just as
a simple example if you want to keep if
you want to keep the purity of your
experiments by keeping them separate
I'll let you know that your competitors
may be running experiments on the same
set of users if you're Amazon you know
if you're Walmart
you but you gotta bet that your users
are also being experimented on by Amazon
so I think Precision is sort of a false
thing to chase after it's better to
figure out this is really understanding
a feature is a binary decision do you
want to ship it or do you want to pull
it back
I have some best practices for data
Champions I'll quickly go over
um this is the image here is actually
from one of our customers Fiona Cummings
from dispatch health so it's she
deserves a credit here for being the
champion of statistical significance and
and using this metaphor there are some
uh these practices come out of a paper
uh that was published
um and really about like if you want to
get started how do you pick your first
set of experiments
um you should find something that's
contentious find something where like
people disagree on whether this feature
is going to work half the people in the
room agree half the people think it's a
bad idea already no matter what the
result of your experiment is half the
people will be surprised
and I've learned something
also it helps teach the team that data
is really the objective decider here
pick something that is impactful that
has high visibility I recommend folks go
for whatever makes money at your company
for example if you are Facebook the ads
team is where you start with because
that gets noticed high up that gets
noticed by all teams
um
so basically teams that drive business
value is usually where you start those
teams typically already have data and
metrics well established
um automation I've mentioned becomes
very important and also just keep
continuing the drive to make
experimentation standard practice
these are still a little bit about my
more my personal notes on sort of the
keys scaling experimentation where I've
seen a few data scientists trip up and
it's like one is like
in the world of experimentation there's
always going to be statistical ambiguity
there's no way to guarantee you're going
to make the perfect decision so you
should embrace it don't worry about
Precision we're able getting quickly to
the right decision worry about making
sure your method is transparent that
people understand things and make sure
things are accessible data scientists
should not be The Gatekeepers and the
only ones running the experimental
analysis data scientists instead should
be the ones driving cultural change
driving teaching people how to use data
how to make decisions being those guard
rails being the keepers of the
data-driven culture
um I'll just give a quick shout out that
we have a booth here we are a sponsor of
Pi data please feel free to stop by if
you want to learn more about
experimentation and that ex and that
using statsig is free for individuals
and small startups and I'm always happy
to chat about anything experimentation I
love to hear what problems folks are
facing and how they've solved them and
I've put up here on the slide a few ways
to reach out to me but finally I'd like
to thank everyone for attending my talk
and I'll take any questions thank you
[Applause]
yeah hi there and things that that's was
an amazing talk
um so to make 10 000 experiments run in
parallel in practice I mean that's like
Facebook scale but
another company I would say like tens of
experiments what kind of recommendations
do you have as of like application
architecture to make these kind of
things possible and what have you seen
that works and doesn't work and what is
the extra cost of doing those
experiments from an implementation
standpoint yeah in the back of my mind
is like the steps of going from zero to
one is a big step uh one to four is
actually a big step but then actually
going past that all the way to ten
thousand it's actually close more
similar than you'd think I think folks
usually like by the time you're running
like half a dozen experiments
simultaneously your teams are already
talking about data they've already
plumbed in metrics they're starting to
do analysis in a scalable way you like
what I've seen in the past as a data
scientist and as someone who's had the
crunch experiments manually it's very
tedious time consuming often requires a
full-time data scientist per experiment
so at some point and I would say like 10
is definitely that number like you don't
want to keep building a larger and
larger data science team and want to
start building the Tooling in place that
has the metrics trustful metrics being
plumbed in that has
a process that Engineers can follow in
order to do it in a safe standardized
way and also start at that scale I would
also start worrying about making sure
you have things like health checks
because it's possible that for example a
metric is not coming in properly or you
may have a sample imbalance that may be
something that the engineer did set up
the experiment incorrectly I think like
at that scale
and that's also the scale that data
scientists starts to step away a bit
and so you hope that you've provided
things like best practices docs you have
engineering Champions Engineers who you
have taught all the principles of
experimentation and they are now driving
that change within their company that's
sort of do you see like micro services
are an architecture that is like
good for these rather than like the
monolith oh absolutely so I think
fermentation is any change should be
tested it's not just the big ones not
just the ones that users can see like
back-end changes for example like stripe
they do a ton of experimentation on
their back end and these are all at the
transaction level these are things that
the users don't see but they but they do
are they are things that you want to
track and make sure that things aren't
regressing when you make them thank you
thanks Tim that has a great talk
um I was wondering if you had any
thoughts on this this challenge that I
often run into with with experiments
um in an early conversation when we're
designing an experiment with stakeholder
usually present a menu of of everything
that we can feasibly measure and we ask
what's important for your intervention
and what you call a success and the
answer I often get is
everything like we want to see
everything right and I get worried about
the multiple comparisons how would you
counter that uh request yeah that's a
problem with when you have too many
metrics and like now I want to see
everything so it's actually almost like
a good thing problem to have but when it
comes to experimentation it's actually
complicates things for some of the
reasons you've mentioned I would always
ask people
what did you expect to happen like what
was your hypothesis or you can even
create that hypothesis after the fact
but like what would you expect to happen
like what is the most immediate thing
that would be the impact that would
happen and then what are the things
Downstream that might be more important
to the business might be related to that
and so the idea is to come up with
ideally like two to three metrics that
are absolutely critical for
understanding making the decision
um but then inevitably when you are in a
room of people trying to look at the
results
um people will come up with alternative
hypotheses and want to look at
alternative ideas that might require new
metrics to look at
um and my personal opinion is that it's
okay to look at those
um but that shouldn't affect your
original decision those can actually be
confirmed in follow-up experiments
whether those ideas work and so that's
sort of a way to sort of bridge this gap
between being statistically rigorous but
also being pragmatic
thank you
got time for one more question
hi I was wondering given your experience
at statsig what is what are some ways to
drive a a collaborative and healthy
culture between the data scientists and
kind of like the data platform team and
what are some of the things that a data
platform team can can build to support
um uh the the data scientists and
running experiments as you've discussed
the data platform team I did not mention
but they are very Central to all of this
the most companies a data platform team
owns the experimentation tooling they
also own the plumbing about being able
to standardize metrics at their company
making sure those metrics flow into the
experimentation system at the your at
your unit of analysis which is typically
the user
um sometimes it could be something
different for the stripe example it
might be that the transaction level but
making sure that's Plumbing in maybe
that makes sure that's working make sure
the numbers are trusted making sure that
that agrees with your source of truth
but also making sure that experimental
results are computed efficiently we just
had somebody mention like you may be
calculating dozens of metrics that's
important to be able to have that
flexibility uh in an experimental setup
those are all the things that I would
just sort of recommend like data
platform is
is really the key part of this and I've
seen in a lot of companies
experimentation can be actually most of
what the data platform does
awesome thank you so much Tim let's give
a big round of applause
thank you